[Music]
submitted by smooth operator to the
title in Disney disease news nothing
else disease smooth
a cooling tower at Disneyland is
suggested to be the cause of an outbreak
of Legionnaires disease Oh God
Legionnaires disease happens to be a
disease caused by bacteria that can grow
in man-made water systems and you kind
of develop sounds like a Roman [ __ ]
army that is your name it's an old
timing thing for sure you develop it
after breathing in like a contaminated
vapor of some sort what are the side
effects
symptoms [ __ ] I don't have any idea it
doesn't say that [ __ ] just as people got
sick they just expect people to know
what Onegin Ares I'm like Legionnaires
didn't know [ __ ]
I mean we all know polio means you can't
walk anymore we don't know Legionnaires
yeah I know chickenpox yeah exactly
Legionnaires like okay the severe form
of pneumonia so basically what it sounds
like Oh see you're really sick it's a
disease disease your water pneumonia is
like water in your lungs headache muscle
pain chills fever of 102
yeah what causes it again there's a
[ __ ] waters old there was a water a
cooling tower yeah and it provides mist
to make all the visitors you know
exactly it's one of those things Wow
so it was like sending out Saddam
Hussein that [ __ ] yeah so so most of the
people who got sick they visited
Disneyland in like the fall of 2017
which is crazy because I'm like wait you
did the mistress run into Nepal bro cuz
it gets pretty high here so in the fall
I guess it does that's true I just
recently got cold here so yeah when I
think of Misty's I'm like it's gotta be
90 degrees bro knife and I'm like
where's the misty like when you go to
Six Flags and you go in a little like
the areas they have the mist yeah
September October not like when it's
like 80 70 I don't maybe I'm just too
cold none are our sons our sons crazy
though like yeah it could be 75 which I
go underneath the Sun Ray and either
they're not in the shadow and you're
standing there for two hours in the line
you're not you shoot you because there
are there are rides that like the I
guess they're not around shady area so
when you're standing there they'll miss
them the sudden [ __ ] Hawaii is
intense dude yeah you step out there son
4:30 mission of skin cancer immediately
it's unreal dude we talking about
California now homey important Coral
sorry I didn't land at the Mojave Desert
now that's a [ __ ] right there
dude that's true I didn't even that's
true and I didn't even think of you're
just standing there
thing is you're just standing wait just
waiting to get skin cancer 80 you're
like [ __ ] anti yeah exactly
well I guess so Disney you're not gonna
leave this they've denied that they're
the source but then what did they do
scientists came well no they point they
said that the the three infected people
who have been in the city of Anaheim
where Disneyland is located but not at
the park itself so how come how come
they got in fact it if they weren't at
the park itself and one of those people
died what yeah one of the people who who
was affected with a more serious his
name we don't know what he looks like so
it's kind of funny it's only three
people that's how we react to news yeah
oh no no so there should be more digital
pointing to three specific people who
got Legionnaires who weren't at Disney
but and one of those people died Oh as a
way to say hey we're not at fault cuz
these people weren't even at Disney and
they said Oh God
but they could have gotten it from
somebody else they get out they're like
well that's what that's what this that's
what it was that Disney I wouldn't even
be like thousands of people right
because so many of you what is like
every
yeah well yeah so they go back to their
country and give it to their [ __ ]
people he's trying to say like yo we
didn't do it we didn't do it cuz there's
other people in Anaheim that dude is me
even if you did I'll go [ __ ] and because
of the way that you can get Legionnaires
it's like like like I said like you can
get it through breathing in like a
contaminated vapor of whatever kind like
you could argue that well it wasn't just
Disney that did it so they'd have to
like really make a direct link between
like Disneyland like water source they
did so they got this disc at dr.
Matthews on Orange County health care
agency and he says that they think that
this is because of Disneyland I guess it
once back here I'm gonna do it to know
she reads while everyone's bantering so
it's like yes yeah but I want to banter
a yes information ready we would like
this like a dead silence no so he says
the contaminant droplets likely hey you
know what I have the balls to say leave
all that [ __ ] in leave it in you know
what she always says okay
hole cut for a second no no I say leave
that [ __ ] in yes I'll show you my flaws
yes
I'm not perfect like tifa's I'll never
be that perfect so no he says
contaminant droplets likely spread to
people in the park and beyond so he's
saying that it likely was sourced at the
park in those walking know started there
he says he's gonna get assassinated
because Disney don't [ __ ] around man
Disney mafias come they're like yo
that's billions of dollars right there
oh yeah cuz that would Disney side right
now you don't know where the [ __ ] you've
got that like if you got like Mickey
Mouse disease where you hit with this
spray of water geyser and then you walk
down you're like hello everybody then
maybe yeah yeah your voice changes a
little bit up get all [ __ ] big and
yellow yeah then maybe I'll see you
hands turn into gloves
yeah what's going on you wanna [ __ ] me
your shirt disappears you have pants I
get a [ __ ] mean eyes widow's peak
yeah
I'm surprised Disney doesn't have like a
[ __ ] I agree button when you enter
their Park saying like give you some of
this [ __ ] do like I'm some sort of right
like is you're like entering in when you
buy the ticket is link probably right
she's real dude that's a real disease
dude well you start rowing a boat
whistling for no reason to have your
foot I'm gonna do the laying on Mondays
but like there's me all the time I'm
[ __ ] loved isn't your your diff think
I have a pass I got no blackout dates is
that one cause now alive are you this so
everyone's like no it's it's not it's
not a celebrity one but it's like the
tops here that would over me and Timmy
we have got gone to Disneyland and got
the celebrity experience oh oh that's a
little tour they yeah where they had us
and Rufio doctor boss no yes and yeah it
was awesome because they were just
taking us in front of every line and
make it by the line it was so sick yeah
those time did you do that secret dining
thing by the a friend of a friend had
like a ticket that they weren't gonna
you towards reservation they were gonna
use then I went with their family it was
really but isn't it like thousands of
dollars no well no it is thousands of
dollars to have the membership to get
the reservation there but because it was
a friend of a friend they have a
reservation that we're gonna use we just
went and only paid the price of the
dinner or how much was the dinner it was
like 50 bucks a plate was it delicious
it was really good yeah it was the
drinks good I was like [ __ ] like 13
did you hear people in Pirates of the
Caribbean go out that's different that's
different even that did you buy you buy
the Blue Bayou inspire as well its way
fired anymore what do you mean alright
every time I've been now it's like so
reserved it's insane you make a
reservation there right like you know I
don't do it puts you like this oh my
[ __ ] God you are badass bro that was
so sick I liked it would you it is what
Disneyland is by far than one of the
most dangerous places I've ever been to
in my life
like Disneyland I I don't understand it
but wait yeah but you've been to
Sacramento Sacramento is the best plugin
orange-trees
no western town though yeah what's the
theme park what's up Arlene Park in San
Francisco that's good yeah that's a deal
and not it's just it's just not it was
fun the first 12 times understand how
much Muriel loves Disneyland she does
what there's so many [ __ ] plans it
big spirit doesn't get better or feel
the same if you keep going you know
space it out that's once you had this
Celebi tour you don't want to do the
common [ __ ] Oh see I never got the
celebrity tour so I got the regular
[ __ ] tour riding like waiting in the
butt and it's just like this thing right
you go in and then I look at other guys
too that are there they're just like
this yeah yeah yeah and then you have
these kids running around screaming all
over the place all the paint's [ __ ]
faded the workers look unhappy
you go through every crevice like you
know if there's like a little story like
paintings issued yes I've been I've been
there a gajillion you had the fire food
though the food is very mediocre it
feels outside of busy no no allow me the
[ __ ] back okay so wait Steve what is
gonna happen if it is it I will feed you
Pizza Rocket I will let you tell me this
is bad Pizza it's good have you been to
the coin dog castle oh the corndog
Castle on me in California Adventure
they got a hotlink corndog the barbeque
place was [ __ ] sick I've had one that
comes out with a bucket the
all-you-can-eat oh yes I'll put it to
you I'm not saying the food is terrible
I'm saying the food is very whatever if
you take that food outside and put in
the real world outside of Disneyland
it's just a Genki you haven't been to
the coin dark castle you haven't eaten
at a little mermaid cafe there
they got lobster nachos so with the
cheese cream cheese that's really good
I've had that [ __ ] macaroni little
thing in a swirl pink had that [ __ ]
Turkey layer that Sebastian Sinead
finger fits in a regular [ __ ] dog
chicken that everybody said was so good
now you been to the communist [ __ ] you
don't know about that know what you're
[ __ ] going let's go let's go we're
shy Nishi hey we should go did you ride
the pirate ship the next time you go you
let me know
cuz anything he's gonna cheer though if
you could convert me to Disneyland
Merrill would be the happiest person on
earth I'll give you the exclusive and
did you know there's a whole ass bars
and Disneyland California benches you
can go get done oh yeah
you're talking more California benches
and isn't it no but then you get drunk
there and you walk over to Disneyland
still decision we spent like the whole
time in Cali adventures cuz I should
Divi you don't like playing on the
island in the middle that's the best
what is that oh it's the stomp sighs I
love you like take a little rap fairy
that's where you go to get hand jobs and
[Laughter]
I'll be honest with you whoever you're
there with hopefully I'm not trying to
get a hand job with the head that big
[ __ ] mouth I like the Pirates ride no
parts great it's just like you want once
you go there once or two or 12 times
it's done you know I mean like you went
too much I haven't gone in like 10 years
12 times in a year
we last was the first time that she
worked there we went there like eight
times in the air and you can go on Space
Mountain six times in a row and then go
do you want to go again and you look at
each other like maybe we've had enough
Space Mountain then you can answer the
question space bugs come on it's fun but
it's like this done anyways next that's
true for an hour and a half awaiting
that's a lot exactly but because we
didn't have to do that [ __ ] Disneyland's
kind of cool
I'm not saying a Disneyland sucks I'm
saying I'm done with it I think that
you're mad because we got the celebrity
name you did here's the thing dog here's
the thing about space mountain if you
even get recognized a little bit on
Space Mountain one of the employees will
come out I just do the Fastpass and you
get there right to the front no no no
you don't get to know
it's pretty quick though it's like it's
like five minutes five ten minutes I
look out the front I'm going on Monday
if you want to come if I have to go with
me if I don't go with this she'll kill
me
bring her legit die how do you get the
VIP treatment for everyone
oh not as no no no you how special said
we now that was maker sturdy we didn't
get that [ __ ] cuz we're celebi's it's
not that she cuz maker was like after
this lubber treat me oh I refuse exactly
you son of a [ __ ]
David son of a [ __ ] you you want that
too slippery treatment though I'm Sonia
that's what I'm not sure that's fair I
will never get the experience you're
like who do I gotta blow to get the line
[Music]